jean-luc and it's recording uh um hi
mommies this episode of your mom's house
you get right into it you don't know
what I feel like we should just get that
out of the way and then we cannot find
you know what I mean you gotta eat your
vegetables before you can have dessert
Tom hold on Oh what's my number do
terrible sound well I'm just making sure
everything is ready to go sound like a
bear like a bear in heat a freak without
warning
is anybody if anyone's checking us out
right now treat me if the audio is cool
yes this is live so if you're listening
to it on your iPod or on your whatever
mom thing is in your ear Tommy can they
see my fat rolls when I sit like this no
baby
they can't see my fat stomach like this
no baby I swear I swear
what is it tits up it's all don't show
my fucking Ferrell's okay it's just
right it's right there okay yeah I know
you're good can I start now yeah yeah
yeah I mean we had to you know shit all
right well this episode of your mom's
house is brought to you by amazon.com
you go to your mom's house podcast.com
where we have our websites and
informations and then there's a banner
there and then you click on that one of
the ways well listen I mean sometimes I
watch Oprah on her network on the Sunday
Soul series and she recommends a book
and you know what I do I go right to our
website I click on the banner and I go
to Amazon accompanied by it look I want
to shout out everybody who has done the
things that we asked you to do and their
loyal listeners and that is you go to
the site you go to your mom's house
podcast calm you've shopped through the
amazon banner we even added the Canadian
banner we have the Spotify banner there
and Spotify if you don't know
I got a really nice email from somebody
this week but explain to people why I
defies the illest thing ever for
instance let's say I'm really into Devo
this week and I was like I want to hear
those songs I grew up on when I was 13
but I still want to buy the album right
well you can do is if you go and you
sign up for Spotify will you go through
our banner right and then you do that
and then you can hear all the songs that
you haven't heard in forever is remember
when you used to get drunk on on
Strawberry Hill wine and listen to Devo
you can do that again in your 30s you
know that you could do that didn't know
you could do that I what was your
favorite song when you were 13 when I
was 13 it was a SWV rain on me yeah
here's an email I got from Nick hey man
I've been using Spotify a lot I signed
up through the banner on your mom's
house podcast calm how you do it I've
listened to 272 songs which I really
only have listened to a fraction of that
but that's how awesome Spotify is I'm I
mainly listen to electronic music and
spotify is the shit because I can listen
to full-on trash without paying for them
find the ones I like a by later tons of
stuff that probably wouldn't have
listened to otherwise that's a nice mix
another cool thing about Spotify is the
sound quality is much better than
YouTube yeah and I haven't even put it
on the high quality setting yet well
wait till that kicks you in your cunt
Mitch
geez you know what that's gonna do when
you listen to the wu-tang and their new
Bowie it's gonna blow your asshole wide
open are you are gonna shit all over
your panties well that's awesome so if
you guys want to experience what Nick is
talking about if you want your asshole
to explode into a thousand pieces from
being so awesome on Spotify yeah that's
how you do it
what's wrong you making you're making
your smelly face man what you smell bear
that's what it is
what is it hold on it's a fucking cunt
thing is it you stream
a dickhead no he doesn't always know
everything all the time hmm he's a
handsome devil but he doesn't know
everything look at the face no no now go
ahead and speak me meow meow meow
everybody yeah that's gonna be much
better is that working
yeah well good so where were we oh it's
modify and that was awesome
um and then dates can we go on to that
are we good yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely um I'm gonna be at hyena's in
Dallas
that's Dallas Tejas that's Texas this
weekend so starting tomorrow the 28th
through Saturday night I will be there
in Tate house and that's where Bill
Hicks is from Tejas and I decided to do
Dallas I've never done it and it's a
really good comedy scene and then after
that I'm gonna be I think July 4th
weekend I will be at levity live and the
Palisades New York oh look at you yeah
just that's just 45 minutes outside of
New York City look at your big old days
and what about you Tommy tea next week I
go to Dayton Ohio to the Dayton funny
bone July 5th through the 8th I do the
Richmond funny bone Richmond Virginia I
go on July 19th oh and then I just had a
date get moved because somebody Katt
Williams took it and took it no I can't
take a man date you motherfucker here's
what got moved I wanna I want to make
sure I heard worse how does he know and
then actually I go right back to Ohio I
do Cincinnati the Newport funny bone
August 2nd through 5th but got moved is
my late date in all
yes at the Cleveland Improv so I won't
be going there but I am gonna be in
Cincinnati August second through fifth
Richmond July 19th
Dayton July 5th through 8th a lot of
doesn't lot of Ohio there's two places
right there out of nowhere one mommy
lots of Ohio yeah so that's that and I
want to make sure everybody knows they
happy and I'm eating some skittles oh
that sounds so much better you like that
oh I like that a lot you can control
your headphone no I know that but for
some reason when you did it from here
yeah feels better blue bands not how
come it was so much better from there
well what blue bands not our blue band
just did something awesome blue band did
something else yeah maybe you should
change your attitude I just ate so much
babe I'm so voice so fast I'm just like
a whole bag of Skittles wait tell us
your chimp smiles you want to start the
show yeah let's start the show
he enjoys their hot Pisac says that
Hina's mom don't see eye to eye on his
love life and he claims that his job is
cost in several relationship please
welcome Robert baguette
is
like that was I
you surprised me the listeners don't
know you guys don't notice but Tom
surprises me almost every time you know
that was amazing
either watching so many clips online
because that gig I got the writing pad
yeah so it requires me to watch I'm
right basically writing this this web
series for some company hired me to do
it and it requires a host right I'm not
the host but I'm I'm writing stuff that
goes back and forth between there's a
lot of videos so like watch these clips
see if these give you ideas so because
of that like you just end up seeing
other clips
yeah I saw that we're research if you
will yeah yeah I mean you end up seeing
shit that like you know it has nothing
to do with your topic but it just cuz
you know it has related videos yeah
stuff and I was like what's this one and
I just I clicked on it you just put that
together that that was Chuck Woolery -
and - of course I didn't know that you
know my mother used to watch this every
night of my life
I've probably like the the typing like
that's the that was a total thing that's
when they on the intro yeah but for some
reason because I wasn't paying attention
to that I thought it was like family
feud or something I don't know it was
like Richard actually yeah
isn't that calling the kettle game isn't
he I don't know anything about jewelry
he wait did you like his likes he's like
he likes cold beer and hot music doesn't
see eye to eye with his mom who does I
love when that's his thing that's mom
about picking the dates together I love
mom
faggot is you know what you think you
would change that right oh can you
imagine the torture you go through with
that I'm a pazsitzky and that's bad
faggot what about like if your last name
is Hitler or Stalin there's no but
there's gay there is you can do white
pages common of course you changed it
that's just silly
it's crazy gay is a common name and that
used to not even mean anything nobody
cared when you were gay last name was
gay there was a football player who
played at Florida State named a Kody fag
FA GG that's just that's a horrible name
man well my friend I'm Shana I believe
has a friend named gain l-like game you
know her mom Shaunie's mom that doesn't
even come close to being Robert faggot
though Begay is her first name
faggot is your last name you're saying
those are comparable well it's some bad
Jordan or no no it's not even close gay
faggot what if your name was gay if your
name was gay faggot that would be like a
fucker that's your name his name was
spelled f AGoT so it's so it's like Lego
like it's French I don't think he says
he was obviously comfortable with with
the pronunciate he would have corrected
him you know yeah go I actually respect
the fact that he was like I'm a faggot
that's the family name and don't don't
think yeah that I have any problems with
that that's my name the name
faggot is rather an odd he said it yeah
you know it is an odd name how about go
fuck your mother chuck like that's
basically what his personality me and my
mom we don't get along you don't get
anything is that she named me faggot is
one of our name main issues that I would
change that one really quick yeah one
during this show was so embarrassing I
mean you would go on a first date and
then they would follow you and then
you'd have to come back and talk about
it I usually by the way something that
we're similar on I used to watch love
connection with my mother shut up
Charlie absolutely a whole world loved
this show still on no Chuck Woolery is
dead by now isn't he I don't know
anything about it he's like a million
years old he was my ultrabac had a heart
attack he did yeah but he's okay
oh good I like Alex Chuck Woolery what a
gig though
do you think he wants to blow
everybody's brains out by now Chuck
Woolery yes he just fucking hates and
yeah so you had a date go fuck yourself
I want to see if this has actual audio
Oh just guys name being said because I
usually they put these highlights I was
trying to get audio of them saying this
guy's name but it's to music do you I
hope you had a good day why oh she's
like so faggot and I I didn't think his
name was an issue until we got to the
restaurant and they're like two faggots
yeah party I know but then it then again
maybe the guy is an awesome guy and like
after you're done going on a day with
him the way you feel is just
maybe that's how they feel after the day
you know maybe that's the audio from
that love connection episode that we
can't find have you thought about you
shitty last name too then word is your
last name there is someone out there
well there's a like ni ger that you know
it's the name of a comfort of a country
so nice yeah I think they actually say
like nice yeah yeah it's like French no
but you're right there's probably
similar you've seen that there's a clip
from have you ever seen that that's kind
of a funny it's very popular a clip from
a it's from a fucking could this thing
be any goddamn slower I'm about to
replace this thing don't you fucking
loses his mind playing video game yeah I
know it's so much fun but why is it so
much fun to listen to someone lose their
shit over something dumb this is a
famous clip from a spelling bee where
Negus Negus what is the language of
origin Ethio into Harwick what is the
definition they king it's used as a
title of the sovereign of Ethiopia
Chennai see the Negus ruled Ethiopia
until the coup of 1974 he has no no shit
smelling bees yeah I one time I forget
what grade it was yeah one time again
the pressure is on
pressures on that's a hard gig I
remember more than anything I remember a
kid that was like pretty smart what's
that sound that's a car that's a car
alarm honking yeah someone just got
jacked all right I just read somebody's
tweet so ridiculous what I can't I can't
even say it don't say it is it an n-word
thing no no no oh we want to encourage
that
no no not even her I'm not encouraging
it I'm just we're just playing clips
from real life this life son
shit's real that's all we know how to do
is be real are you trying to say that I
can't be real on this show and yeah I am
keeping it real let's keep it real
keeping it real
that kid ended up spelling it right he
did yeah but he didn't know what he was
doing he was like I don't fucking know
the word is spelled by the way and
eg us and even though these the guy
who's in charge of the spelling bee is
saying
Negus the according to this video it's
correctly pronounced nee goose so he was
mispronouncing it right when he was
giving the kids a lesson or giving the
kid the word well it's an Ethiopian word
that's not a very easy language it's not
easy it took me like a year now Aaron I
speak fluent Ethiopian oh do you
remember when you were kid and you
learned that like faggot also meant like
a bundle of sticks no I didn't learn
that when I was a kid you know when I
learned it when I was 32 do you ever
have moments like that where you're like
how did everybody know this but me
because that's what I you never did that
when your kid and never knew that are
like you learned that faggot was a
cigarette in England and then you
remember will have a fag a fag yeah not
a faggot but you just said I remember
learning that fag was a cigarette and
and thinking of course I was a kid that
was hilarious yeah and it's still like
would make me turn my head like in
London when you would hear somebody like
yeah dude like it's hard to wrap your
head around that one okay but I never
learned about the bundles thing I
learned about that when I was 32 yeah I
learned about it at a bar there's a bar
downtown that has a huge like it has all
these like antique stuff and like cool
retro posters and ads and like just
stuff from all over the world and one of
them is this big sign that says like we
have like just I forget like we have all
the faggots you need or something and I
was with Matt Braunger and I was like
they says that that's that's not nice
and he was like ah you know but you know
what that is and I was like nah
you know that's the love you thanks babe
do you um I remember when I learned what
a what a dyke was mm-hmm
I thought that word was the funny I
still do think tykes really funny but to
put your finger in a dike yeah comedy
gold
sure for ten years a 10 year olds can't
go wrong with that my mom taught me what
a dike was and I fucking lost my mind
yeah yeah I understand that I think I
use that word in therapy they're doing
by the way I just uh
remember that like the expressions like
we always talk about that when people
will be like it's a blessing in the sky
yeah in disguise yeah you've missed
you've misheard it yeah your whole life
and I what's the other one is like with
by all for all intents and purposes I
didn't I didn't know that until like a
year or two ago yeah I thought it was
like for all intensive purposes
you had no idea yeah yeah see I also
didn't understand how to pronounce words
correctly cuz my my family mispronounced
them cuz her phone oh yeah yeah like my
mom instead of saying martyr would say
Marty er not being a Marty er you know
that's one of my mom's favorite words
too it's Kappa yeah when you're like if
you're ever not doing exactly what they
want when they somebody's a martyr
you're being you're being such a martyr
and you're like alright having your own
identity and you're having your own
personality trying to be a martyr yeah
god forbid you don't want to do what
they want you to do all the time all the
time it's called having a personality
mommy and identity mom can you deal with
that
mmm-hmm anyways somebody I must say it
was very gassy this week who and it's
somebody sitting across from me
oh well somebody has reciprocated with
those gassing notions first of all it's
turning into summer here in Los Angeles
and we moved into this home it's an
old-ass house and you saw that there was
no wall unit no AC unit what did you do
freak the fuck out I lost my shit
I was completely unconsolable that's how
I felt you were really you were just
that angry I was really raging we got in
here and I saw that there was because by
the way it's been multiple places that
I've lived and it's always a Los Angeles
thing by the way this is very West Coast
when they tell you like you got windows
and tell you the truth you don't really
need more than that here a lot of
landlords will be like you know I spent
plenty of time here and a nice breeze
and you'll be fine the summers aren't
hot that is a load of shit also a big
load of shit is the whole notion of like
it's dry heat it's not as bad not as bad
as the East Coast were it's so humid
fuck you you have no idea what you're
talking about it gets hot as mother fuck
here yeah it's Mexican it's exactly it
is a desert this is basically a little
bit cooler than Vegas and that's it
it's hot as shit here and July August
September and October are on bearable
and if you don't have air conditioning
get ready for the seventh circle of hell
because it's going to be really shitty
well and what they do - there's like one
old-ass wall unit and a place it cools
the whole place down yeah we've had that
unit since 78
it just really kicks the shit out of
everything the last place I lived in the
neighborhood my landlady did that hole
just open the window fan when it's
August and it's like a hundred fifty I
am the rollable one that is the biggest
mistake never okay here's what I did cuz
I was living and it was hot as shit and
I hundred stairs yeah I lived on a stair
Street which is like these old
historical houses in Silver Lake so you
literally add no driveway literally if
you want to go home to my house need to
climb 150 steps and it was so goddamn
hot and I was so broke but I I thought I
spent a $500 and I put on a fucking
credit card needed and I got this AC
unit
didn't you lug it up the stairs for me
yeah probably
and this thing wait I can't how much do
you think that thing weighed man at
least a hundred pounds you have to wheel
it from room to room and then it comes
the tube and then you have to put the
tube out the window so that the exhaust
and the heat or whatever I can go out
made it bearable man it made it bearable
it sucks in the warm air and it spits
out cold air that's how that works right
those things and it was the loudest
thing and I didn't tell my landlady she
got the electrics like leaving your
lights on like yeah yeah yeah all 65 of
them yeah really those lights
yeah but did that saved our asses so in
this house we moved in well the one
don't forget when I lived in that other
place with Brian yeah dad had the it had
the AC unit in the living room was one
of those deals listen we used to live
here it's more than enough not even it
it's more than enough yeah cool is the
whole goddamn place down pulls down shit
if this place was eight thousand square
feet this little one window unit would
cool everything down just a couple
months into that I was fucking running
to Home Depot getting another window
unit this place and this place I
remember us saying we need a window unit
in the person being like yeah yeah and
then when we showed up that day she was
like Oh what I meant was that you could
put one in it was it was definitely a
shady miscommunication but you know what
I'm over it all I know at day one
well let's be real here I fix it because
we came in we were moving is it like the
day we were moving I think was the day
we were moving by the way you can look
it up it was in October and if you look
it up
it was October 2010 mmm it was a 2010
taxi we went to England yes Russell
Peters that's right so October of 2010
you can look it up the day that we moved
in was the hottest day on record that
they have in modern history in Los
Angeles in other words for like the 90
years they've been keeping temperatures
the day that we moved in was
the single hottest day that they thought
it was like I think it was 1:13 at the
very least yeah it was we were moving
out of the ghetto we're moving out of
like the rampart division finally and
back to the good neighborhood and
remember are moving guys
those poor Mexican dudes yeah they were
like they had to take a siesta in the
middle of the day and they had to drink
6 or a beer and sleep in the shade he
was like I worked better when I drink
and I was like hmm and then he took his
nap he was like I was like you gotta
knock some time off for like your nap
and stuff it was like come on man and I
was like so then you don't get a tip he
was like you have to tip me I was
looking you had to talk knock down a
couple hours oh yeah he was like doing
this whole thing's like I can't I was
like dude what's it gonna be it's either
gonna be one or the other either get a
tip or you gettin knocked at I'm like
which is it gonna be he was like all
right and I also bought them tacos
remember yeah so anyway we come here the
day we're moving in yeah and I see that
he sees Tommy sees there's no wall unit
yeah loses your your atomic meltdown
could we had to sleep there that night
the hottest day of the year so what do
we do this is I recommend anybody if you
do it if you got to save your life go to
Sears telling your predicament the
fucking come the day of these guys cut a
hole in our wall because it's like an
old-ass plaster wall shove that fucking
through there and you know what it was
worth every penny I put on the Sears
card might still be paying it off but
you know what you gotta do it you gotta
do it but now and then the price when
that air when that AC first came on I
was like
nice that's it
I remember you saying that over and over
that's how I felt that was the sentiment
that was emotionally that's how I felt
I wasn't being raised of talking about
the AC unit yeah but can I tell you that
now that that AC units become the bane
of my existence
because you turn it full blast in our
bear cave yeah and I the other night you
turned it on so high and I was freezing
like you know when you feel like
feverish like Oh am I getting sick cuz
my bones are hurting I woke up shivering
in a cold sweat because I tried to cover
myself to compensate for the cold air
and I realized it was because you would
sabotage me basically don't do anything
nice for anybody mm-hmm is the point of
the story especially if you're married
and then the farts added to that that
night I gotta say I bet I bet everybody
would agree with me on this pole there
is nothing in the world better than
making your room an ice box and then
you're getting under a blanket so the
rooms like 45 50 degrees when you get on
I mean can you get a better situation
for sleeping I don't think it's possible
I like you know what I like what balmy
80 in the house Oh summertime I like to
crank it up I like it 80 degrees I like
to walk around and just like a t-shirt
and my panties on I don't like to be
cold you know that nothing's better
presenting this is the end of my my
awesome months in this house now it's
it's your regime so the winter time is
my regime I gave it to balmy 82 now this
is your turn to fucking winner
I yeah you know what though I even get
ahead of yourself in the winter because
a lot of times in the winter somebody
you get up in the middle of the night
and turn the heat down cuz it's so
excited about this
you're like holy shit fart and then you
fart right next to the air conditioner
now the boiler farting you're next to
the AC unit and then when you fart it
blows
directly into my face now I wanted to
point out that I didn't mention this I
was in Grand Rapids over the weekend
right I had a great time there yeah your
shows he said fucking had a blast at
their shows did you fart for them too I
farted a few times but the whole thing
was that I was really surprised at how
much I liked the city like I thought
Grand rapid I didn't know what to expect
it was really nice
it wasn't a fucking piece of shit
yeah and the club was nice and the shows
were a great audience man just fun
really good audience I really really
really enjoyed myself in Grand Rapids at
doctor grins maybe maybe you farted for
them they wouldn't like you I don't know
I'm so mad at you for farting as much as
you do please and one thing else I
wanted to play for you you didn't expect
this but you know um a couple days ago
was the anniversary of Michael Jackson's
death ya know I went and I dug up our
favorite clip about that hi this is
congressman pete king and yesterday I
marched into fucking July parades and
what tour and Massapequa Park today I'm
just taking a walk through Montoya here
to North Arlington Boyle
firehouse down the street a fire
memorial a few blocks from here and it
really reminded me of the other great
men and women who have sacrificed so
much for our country people fighting in
Iraq and Afghanistan
they agreed firefighters teachers don't
really get much credit yet for the last
I don't know how long now just slow like
Michael Jackson his name is face picture
he's all over the newspapers television
radio so we hear about is Michael
Jackson Hamlet's knock out the
psychobabble
this guy was a pervert it was a child
molester
they in and day out
what's this a virus in our country I
just think it's ooh it would support a
clicker Ecch no one wants to stand up
and say we don't need michael chats you
know you died it's talent define the
people dying everyday there's men and
women dying say in Afghanistan let's
give them the credit they deserve I
really think the media has disgraced
itself I think they're too many people
in public life have made fools
themselves by talking about Michael
Jackson's if there's some kind of hero
maybe a good singer dancing everything
the favorite my favorite line of the
last three years is he made a may have
some songs did some dancing some singing
dancing as like as how would you
summarize Michael Jackson singer did
some dancing did some dancing is my
favorite thing ever
I'm going to play it again immediately
right now pretty good maybe a good
singer did you dancing but the bottom
line is would you let your child a
grandchild be in the same room with
Michael Jackson
what
so anyway let's take some time out to
really hooks the people at to make us a
great country the men and women of the
Armed Forces police firefighters
teachers who work in really rough
neighborhoods people who volunteer with
dying cancer patients people who work in
AIDS clinics they're the ones we should
be a glorifying not some I did I did for
it had a salad Sal make you far you know
did that guy win he was running for
office he's in office that wasn't a
speech you know he was already a
congressman at them no I didn't I
thought that was that was speech the guy
did some dancing singing some dancing
this guy's a pervert you wouldn't leave
your kids with him that's the best thing
you can I tell you that I talked about I
just say one thing about Michael Jackson
on stage yeah and I say that he was
fucking kids and people still go ah he
was no he was I think there's something
to be said about Michael Jackson first
of all he's not just a guy who as as
this Peter King pointed out may be a
good singer
did you dancing he also he did do was a
good singer and he did do some dancing a
little dance just one happened to death
I happen to agree with the notion that
he is the greatest entertainer of the
modern of modern times I mean who's
fuckin better than listen here's my
stance no no I'm talking I don't give a
shit he was no no no no no that's that's
ridiculous to say you mean to tell me
bad and be everything after bad was a
good thing are you discrediting what he
did as the jacket with the Jackson 5
like that I said after bad is garbage
everything before the man was good and
then it's garbage no I disagree yeah
you agree what were you gonna say before
did you know shit
you're like my gypsy husband yeah I mean
that's retarded that's one of the
dumbest fucking things you've ever said
that was the dumbest one one of them
that's fucking stupid
he's probably I dare you that is stupid
he's one of the greatest entertainers of
all time
probably the greatest entertainer of the
last hundred years and I think this is
this is something that what people do is
that when somebody who's so talented
does something horrible then we we don't
want it to be so we want to remember and
glorify and just Revere all the talent
stuff and you don't deal with the flaws
it's kind of like what's his name Roman
Polanski is such a talented filmmaker he
fucked that girl when she was 13 he's a
shit and you know he did it with booze
and like they did this thing now we're
like they've made up she holds nothing
against him I think they even did it
like in a film or something where she's
like I forgive you this is nonsense the
guy fucked a 13 year old girl
after getting the booze yeah and you
know if that had been a bus driver or a
teacher or a policeman we wouldn't be
like but he's a great guy you just be
like there's a piece of shit but if he
makes great films then you find it in
you yeah and then I know the argument by
the way that I've seen I've read books
about it I've seen the film about how
the judge told him it was going to be
this and then he flipped it on him at
the end right I don't care like I really
don't care that that's what happened to
him
I still think the guy he's a great
filmmaker but he's still kind of a piece
of shit I think too you know I think
Hollywood gives leniency
yeah these scum fuck douchebag pieces of
human garbage yeah Michael Jackson was a
fucked up dude
yeah he was raised in a fucked up house
he had a fucked-up childhood and I also
I do recognize that he was he was
because because you did I also recognize
that he was found not guilty and I don't
care
I still think
he fucked those kids I think he fucked
dozens of boys and you know well can I
tell you why I think he did too
despite the fact that he's found not
guilty or whatever is that look twenty
kids don't come forward with that kind
of stuff and their families and all that
if there's no with her smoke there's
fire right that's how the expression
goes where there's farts there's fire
yeah and this guy for sure because you
and I don't get accused of fucking kid
nope why cuz we don't fuck with kids now
don't have kids over we don't do shit
with kids no he's a fucking PDF file his
top top I would say happens but can i I
will contest this greatest Entertainer
of all time mm-hmm
I don't know I I will admit that up
until like I said the bad album I I
liked the moonwalk was but you know the
moonwalk he ripped off of street
performers who cares and he was a great
singer as a kid he did some that
thriller was amazing off-the-wall
amazing look if you had one of those and
you had half of one of those you're
already like wonderful way to make the
greatest of all time and he puts tape on
his goddamn finger I'm not saying the
guy was sensible and and then all of a
sudden he's grabbing his cock and yeah
bad and he's a bean motherfucker and
then he loses his god yes I agree mine
and everything bill garbage don't rate
us entertainer though I could honestly
and let's be honest I am being honest
past that victory tour with he and his
brothers and thriller past the throw
album I am NOT interested in him I
understand I didn't like a fucking not a
thing that the guy did because remember
that weird video he did with Priscilla
that's late when they're new that was
garbage there's a lot of bullshit but
I'm saying this lost his mind but it
still doesn't take away that from the
fact I don't think that he saw the great
Tina Turner is great she's one of the
greatest entertainer she's been doing it
since she was like 12
she doesn't what's his name she can't
sniff his jockstrap that is fucking
virgin
eugen the 80 good for her no comparison
to me none I am anime you got to sing
the motherfucker with motherfucker she
was supposed to be saying you're like
you remember that movie you're like that
spent like you're married to somebody
and then you realize there's some things
and they talk about they're like wow you
don't know what the fuck you're talking
about this is like this isn't yeah I
keep doing a monkey face this is like
you're talking about medicine or
something how do you let's fucking move
it along whatever what else you guys
what you got son
this is how your people do it Tommy
you know what it's time for fill up that
couch drop loads in it and feel it shot
this first one I got from a listener and
it's actually a mail edition it's a
little space edition if you will here we
go fill er up ceiling shut yes have our
two candidates Captain Picard
or Han Solo you have to explain for each
character's from this oh sorry
Captain Picard is that old bald guy from
Star Trek The Next Generation mm-hmm
right are you saying right you didn't
use that guy right no I don't want Lenny
looking laughs like I don't have hours
to fucking oh sure Luke picked out
jean-luc Picard okay
that's Andy's ball he's old but he looks
kind of stoic and sexy hey playboy
Patrick Stewart Star Trek next
generation I mean this is really or Han
Solo of course Harrison Ford's character
in the Star Wars trilogy original
trilogy I think this is really just
gonna show us who who's a Trekkie and
who's Star Wars fan because their Trek
hardcore Trekkies want to get filled up
by that bald head then I would take it
back to Captain Kirk maybe we should do
Captain Kirk maybe you should do a
little bit of fucking preparation that
was busy time which is it I mean you're
the one fucking time say what now I'm
gonna revise it because I was looking at
Captain Picard he's not he's not a
stone-cold Fox
Jesus what I mean I just wish you would
fucking let's do this I do give a shit I
just revised it on the flight look I can
go with it I can change things on the
fly can I not I can change my
men decisions okay Han Solo versus
what's a girl Captain Kirk Shatner in
his prime back in his day yeah alright
that's a much better one buy though
that's what I'm saying I didn't look
look mistakes were made
upon further alright look from now on
only I'll handle these guys he's so
macho today your balls are full you need
to be milked you're very aggressive so I
mean for me it's his fucking hands down
the easiest thing ever is gonna be a
landslide it's Han Solo are you fucking
it's Harrison Ford he's the coolest
thing ever I would let Han Solo do awful
things to me wild Chewbacca watch I
would let Chuy sit on my face if I knew
that the Han was downstairs
Wow wouldn't you I would let Han Solo do
all kinds of terrible things to be sure
even if I was his sister was I'd say but
ya know it's not his father Luke sister
Princess Leia
so Harrison Ford can fuck Princess Leia
totally he does on the regular got a
little space baby
absolutely you think you cute now cute
oh yeah I would I would do Han Solo too
cuz he's a stone-cold Fox yeah and
Harrison Ford is very intelligent
interviews and stuff he's like super
yeah but you're not fucking Harrison
Ford you fucking han solo man I'm sorry
yes the wear his lightsaber yeah of
course his gun belt what I'm talking
about Harrison Ford is Johan peasant
shirt he wears like a peasant shirt just
like the other side of this is who would
you rather fill up or seal shut Princess
Leia
or precious wait a minute
and is it going to be obvious precious
precious no because some people are into
big chicks that's true I know that guy
you know I'm - he really likes them - I
really do dudes brother remember really
I mean he likes some real big yeah no
okay can we do okay so we both say oh by
the way then let's let's pinpoint this
outside I do like people doing that I
think this is really fun we got to get
this link on our site on your mama's
house podcast I can but on Facebook
there's a fan page yeah and you can vote
and you can post your comments and you
can you can do all kinds of oh yeah
that's what the poll on our website they
smell what you're saying I can do that
no no I'm not saying to do that at all
got your hear you loud and clear Tom if
you go to facebook.com slash your mom's
house podcast it's our fan page if
you're on Facebook and you like it
we post there there's all kinds of stuff
people comment all there whatever
thoughts there's just all kinds of fun
shit there and there's always polls for
this so there will be a poll where you
can click on whether you want Han Solo's
deep dicking or you want Captain Kirk to
do the fucking thing up and you'll have
two in your couch and two in your ass
the Shocker babe or if you want to bang
precious or Princess Leia lactic shocker
but that's not the second one I had for
today
who'd you have that's not a real one you
guys don't let Tom fool that is a real
one you were really into precious versus
Leia that's kind of a hands down
everybody knows that it's precious
duh okay then what did you have in mind
okay well for a superhero edition for
girls okay
I would do for the guy okay this one's
for you guys Wonder Woman the Lynda
Carter Wonder Woman from seventies and
eighties TV show or Catwoman Michelle
Pfeiffer a version of Catwoman so
Michelle Pfeiffer Catwoman or Wonder
Woman he decided not to take how they
bury interesting I forgot that she did
okay well hmm I like the Michelle fight
for a Wonder Woman better I like that
one better okay well that's ducks you
said you guys know what it is
Wonder Woman Lynda Carter or Michelle
Pfeiffer I'm going without Mekhi Phifer
not to be confused right - I'm going
with Lynda Carter Wonder Woman I like I
like her I like the og Lynda Carter
I like og Wonder Woman I like that
outfit more and I feel like I would like
to be dominated by her in that outfit
and I bet her pussy has more special
powers than Catwoman's puss he's just
gonna have like tuna fish falling out of
it and it's gonna be extra stinkier
because she's a cat it's already a
stinky pussy - now she can have a real
stinky claw Phil there's hair balls
falling out of her puss Lynda Carter is
gonna have sugar tits
and her pussy's gonna have chocolate
syrup that fall Lynda Carter the party
starter the party starter she's gonna do
magical things I think and I bet you
heard dick like gives you like
electroshock like her dick a her pussy -
your dick like your dick it was like oh
like you really do scream yeah you know
I mean that's a really good assessment
you bet yeah shave with our future
children I bet when you're when you're
fucking Lynda Carter your life
yeah that's how it goes uh okay can I
tell you mine yeah I grew up loving
Wonder Woman I had the underoos to prove
it
yeah however Oh curveball coming right
now bang bang I happen to like Catwoman
better because of my goth leanings I
like the outfit I like her powers listen
one woman had an invisible jet which is
kind of dumb and then lasso of truth
which is fucking gay oh yeah
Catwoman could scale shit and she could
do sneaky stuff you know hi I'm light I
guess so
I like Michelle Pfeiffer in that movie
does she licked her yeah and she goes me
yeah she's just mean oh no one could
tear your cock off from the base with or
less know shoot I that's around your
bean bag I wonder like that and then she
would just with her hands just tear that
shit off Catwoman would bad at your bean
bag
oh speaking of fucking and claw your
asshole shut yeah bloody dude let's talk
about this yeah yeah you guys know topic
you guys know um go to the site go to
your mom's house podcast calm but also
go to the Facebook page which I had up a
second ago facebook.com slash your mom's
house podcast
check it out like it and comment okay
this what's that what do you hold just
get almond eat it okay
this is what I talk to you about
softcore porn we here's what we're doing
we were watching something on the DVR
the digital
video recorder thing and it had whatever
was on live TV was on it was on Showtime
I think so when we ended what we were
watching on the DVR the you know the
recording goes off and it goes back to
live and what was live was a terrific
film a feature film a feature film
called bikini airways that we just we
couldn't stop watching it is terrible I
mean it is terrible and it really got us
thinking about like who is this made for
right like I understand the thought
behind it it's like there's different
levels to it where you go like oh it's
it's probably like a filmmaker who
wishes he could make real films and
can't so he's got this on definitely
actors who thought hey this could be an
intro into legit I could be on ER next
week I can be here it's a credit yeah
you need credit and and it's not just
just like nyeh log is terrible the sets
are terrible the cinematography is
terrible the sex scenes which are
supposed to be the highlight are the
worst the whole horrible
and then we go like well who like who
wants to watch softcore sex it makes
sense it's not even sex right it's a
softcore scope great right but I'm
saying that it's not even real fucking
they're pretend humping right see that's
what's awful is dry hump each other
sometimes you'll see a ball bag or a
cock sock you'll see you'll see
movements that are supposed to mimic sex
but if you've ever had sex in your life
one time you'll know that like that's
not a sexual movement like because of
the way that the Anatomy works between
human males and human females doesn't
plug in that way the thing that they're
doing that doesn't make sense so the
whole thing but then it's like so then
you you try to fit them together like
well you know why is this existing but
then the thing you have to go to is
there has to be an audience for it
somebody likes and my theory on who's
softcore porn is for is that it's for
the guy
who's probably married probably old a
little bit older who wants to watch porn
right but can't deal with what that
feels like to look for it and watch it
so this is like it's almost like a guy
who drinks nyquil because he doesn't
want to go buy a bottle of whiskey or
something yeah it's like yeah I think
that's who it's for I think if there's a
guy that's there's men who oh my god
this is on and they can't deal with like
searching for it online buying a video
so they just go no you know what I just
figured it out boo-boo yeah that was the
theory before like what if these guys
are just a sheltered and like if you
happen to stumble upon it it's okay I
think it's actually guys whose wives and
girlfriends don't allow pornography in
the house right and this is one of those
things like that was on Showtime yes
that's what I'm saying no it's like an
extension of that okay so but the
actually it's under fear of being caught
with legit porn right and then they
scurry off and watch the Showtime but I
thought you meant it was shame based
meaning like I can't I feel weird
downloading no no I feel weird no I
think it's like I can't be caught with
that right I will get she will fucking
murder me if she knows it's done in this
awful fucking show and here's here's
real gentlemen this is your captain
speaking we're gonna be flying today
between all five thousand and forty five
thousand feet we're not quite sure we
want to welcome you to
hugh janus airlines the big red eye Oh
Suffolk correction the recently renamed
bikini Airways like flying on cloud 69
back where the plane is to strip down as
the girls who fly now I'm in the event
of a sudden cabin pressure well it's
really no big deal
we're in charge so we'll be fine and now
we would encourage you to all please
strap in your seat belts those of you
who have a seat belt those who don't
please hold on to those who do
we'll get back at you so this we're it's
Phil Phil with these bad jokes horrible
jokes the whole time bad act over and
then like the over the guy with the I'm
taking pictures of people you can tell
that the setup doesn't match the other
was set up like because they filmed on
separate days they only had the set for
a certain amount of hours I mean I do
the fuck's or though and they didn't
want the fuck people didn't want this
guy to walk in there
so slow Jesus Christ
it's - it already wouldn't want anything
you have to be honest and I remember it
took like 20 minutes before anyone
tended to hump remember that is all this
exposition and story and you're like you
stupid fucking story it's just bad
the whole time and the story of the girl
inheriting an airline you have to know
the entire backstory of every care I
just want to see them naked just anybody
shit like oh look at these papers what
does it say well oh no it says this
means we are instructed to make contact
with male species of Earth have vigorous
sexual activity with them and then bring
the most potent specimen back to Agra
Tara for Queen Morgana's aboard a ship
you know what we want we want to fucking
turn something on crank it out cuz to me
pornography like here's the thing if
that softcore shuts on versus a normal
movie like I mean other than us making
fun of it which we were doing you're not
gonna watch the softcore porno porno
movie and be like what's happening
yeah what's gonna happen to these people
like when you watch pornography there's
a utility get in this you get off you
get out
and the sex in your life in these
softcore films are upsetting is it
supposed to upset you to watch your film
like why is it have to be upsetting you
know like jokes are terrible so bad
whatever you've got
okay there you go
well after we get off and all the girls
are like in the softcore ones they're
less hot than in the hardcore ones right
they're like they're not hot enough to
model they're definitely not hot enough
to be like hey I'm a hot actress they're
like they're the ones that get like
they're like turned down from like hot
roles but they're willing to get naked
like I've seen a lot of ugly porno
chicks - well there's that too but
there's also some good-looking ones
right like I feel like these are like
did drugs I knew a girl that did this
stuff I did a pilot with this one girl
and she's like it's not like sex
Christina because I wear a cooter cover
is what she called it and then the guy
wears a sock yeah I'm like oh so she
they were like a thing right her vag
yeah and then he covers it with a sock
right in that way but that's how they
justifying I'm not making a porno I'm
just acting right with this thing and
I'm naked acting mm-hmm which I mean I
good and his balls are still slamming up
against you yeah everybody sees it
could it be slower like you said yeah
fucking move it along
high-five
ten minutes of titty liquor makes me
crazy when they just can't yeah they
just kiss boobs for but when I saw this
shit when I was like like in junior high
didn't this blow your mind when you saw
your first softcore porn on like cable
TV late at night at your friend's house
or whatever you're like whoa
this is what do what it is Horace Mann
of course I mean first time but maybe
that's what this is for like decision
introductions to teach children how to
have sex yeah this is what we want to
see though nobody wants to see you're
signing up really overdrive maybe this
is real you know that was real I mean
the action was real oh right yeah she's
really getting pounded yeah yeah I
wonder what that is there has to be it
must be the psychological thing of like
I don't actually want to see sex happen
like those the same people that are on
that seven days of sex show that can't
say the word sex oh my god we're having
s so real quick tomorrow I'm gonna send
out a bunch of stuff the people have
ordered so I want to thank everybody
thank you guys
your kingfish stuff your highest
tightest jeans bundles and the top dog
shirts I got the place to do a rush on
them and they're coming out July 3rd I
picked them up and I go straight to ship
them so they will all ship on July 3rd
they are really cool you can order them
if you want one go to your mom's house
podcast calm and you can find them there
and on
that little note hey buddy
stop dog hey buddy it's top dog hey
buddy it's top dog you need to lie down
the shirts out off the chain you guys
really responded in a way so cool it is
really fucking rad I'm super excited
about this top dog shirt I feel like
this is the shirt of the podcast forever
and ever amen
it's gonna be ours there's some stuff
that we we started on last week I
figured we'd pick up where we left off
and then just kind of go from there man
banking beat it up and tossed it out
that was that wasn't so should we recap
for people who haven't listened if you
haven't yeah if you haven't listened
last week's episode of course we we
talked about the shitting the pants that
happened two episodes ago we recap that
and got his take on what happened couple
five feet too far and ask some other
questions about smells and what those
indicate to you and then we we got into
picking up chicks and he laid down his
old game his the game he used to spit
was two bank tellers very specific he
gave really carrying really detailed
instructions just listening for the
first time especially if you're trying
to get laid and the banking in the
financial industry
maybe you should go listen to episode 63
and let him put you up on game you know
it's really surprised that time had such
a specific game I did not I did not see
it coming I did not know that was coming
I don't think anybody did it I think we
all just thought he was good at smelling
his own farts right sharding but yeah
get a plan to know that he's got these
skills with chicks I mean oh yeah this
is really something else it really is so
we got into that
and how dating worked and then well this
is where we left off one no your hell
are you now 64 64 yeah back in your
single days okay go right so we're
talking you know over 30 years ago how
when you went out with and you were you
know you know you had intimate relations
with a woman
what type of protection did you guys use
back then oh we didn't we just took her
took her chances every single time every
single thing every single time with
every girl yes have you ever worn a
condom mmm no is do you think that's
normal
no did people back then wear condoms
they were hard to get because they
didn't you know they sold them in
restaurant to really seedy gas stations
how's it yeah or that it would be the
pharmacist of Madam behind the counter
there nobody wanted to ask him so he
kind of just took their chances so every
you're just a young girl every single
time isn't that incredible bananas I
can't even go back then we're condoms
they were hard to get because they
didn't looks clear that again they sold
them in restaurant to really seedy
gastacius
how's it yeah or they the the pharmacist
some had him behind the counter but
nobody wanted to ask him so he kind of
just took their chances so every single
girl every single time was Russian
roulette you know and this never ended
in a pregnancy you don't think a couple
scares with no pregnancies that you know
of yeah well I know I mean I just you
know I wasn't that active for games I
don't I don't I think I have a brother
definitely there's a there's a junior I
think I have a brother or sister junior
who's 48 see you had but the ones that
you dated you dated some of them
ya know you might have another son or
daughter out there now because I really
wasn't I mean the ones that I did I
really was pretty conservative actually
and they didn't take the pill or
anything well how long ago what did the
Pokemon well beats it they had it but it
just kind of started yeah you know this
is we're talking late sixties early
seventies okay is that another one of
your models just rush like just take a
shot and see what happens
well in those days you know a lot of
that what I'm yeah yeah yeah would you
have
what if somebody came up today next week
to your office and was like I am your
son right down to the DNA lab
immediately
okay and if it was confirmed it is
confirmed yeah are you taking about the
dawn I probably take you out to dinner
yeah